[Music]
you see half a daughter and she's a girl
and I will educate her you know I mean
her whatever she won I will give but
none bad things not bad things but good
things and that means land and a house
Kazi men work on their wives land at the
moment they're harvesting Laurel this
landowner has a son and also much to her
satisfaction two daughters in pervy
society overall responsibility lies with
mothers the mother is the head of the
family when she dies her daughter
inherits her property that's how it's
been for generations the Kazi practice
matrilineal descent the youngest
daughter of the family the Kakadu
inherits all ancestral property sons
live with their mothers until they get
married then they move in with their
wife's family every time a daughter
marries the family extends the property
to accommodate her new family our
children have their mother's name not
their father's name your task as a man
is to fulfill your family's needs the
women are in charge of the home and the
property they make sure everything runs
smoothly in the state of Meghalaya the
Kazi who number roughly 1 million are
officially recognized as an ethnic
minority they enjoy certain privileges
with Kazi laws protected by an
autonomous district government they also
pay lower taxes and benefit from India's
employment reservation policy for
government and public sector jobs Indian
culture tends to favor boys over girls
but in Kazi culture a family with no
girls is considered unfortunate men are
financially dependent on their wives
barely any registered cases of domestic
violence in the afternoon to the women
like to meet up for tea and gossip in
more long burner from farmers to
business women everyone here chats
together comfortably Kong ARB is the
owner of the tea house I sell tea and
light snacks I provide for my own
children and my whole clan I don't earn
a lot but it's enough for my family Cong
RB is determined to protect Kazi
tradition from outside influences a
woman I'm very proud of our tradition
men move in with their wives they look
after us and they also help us look
after the children it's good to be a
woman here but life isn't always easy
for the Kakadu from an early age
youngest daughters have to take care of
their families they look after the
younger children and the extended family
cook clean and wash clothes they're also
expected to take care of their parents
and grandparents until they die Indian
society is largely male dominated and
Kazi men are often the butt of jokes but
they themselves have no problem with
women ruling the roost my wife should
respect me a lot and also respect her a
lot but we what each other with respect
for keeping our children's for
developing their future when a girl or
boy signs but love is more important I
loved her she loved me and supporting
for children that is people Isha is
renovating her mother's market stall
she's just 18 and still goes to school
but she's already the head of her family
still she's optimistic about the
it's not important because after we work
after we get a job Melissa can make
money and then we can you know for our
parents we can we could put a meet at
home take care of them and for us after
a second job and go for traveling but if
she's to uphold tradition as well
she'll have her work cut out for her
however one tradition remains
unchallenged Meghalaya villages are
considered the cleanest in the whole of
Asia that women are constantly cleaning
and tidying and Broomsticks from more
Langner a popular tourist souvenirs
broom grass grows here everywhere
it's handpicked by the women and bound
to make the brooms one feature of cozy
culture at least that has been exported
all over South Asia